- Good morning, Believe Nation,
today's message is push more!
Over to you, Jennifer Aniston.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I was saying the other day to somebody,
I think all actors who are, maybe,
gratefully are successful,
sometimes if you are
identified with something like Friends,
you almost feel like you're
an actor in a closet,
always trying, like, I want to
do more, you know what I mean?
And it's always, there's
always a little bit
of a struggle and a challenge.
But I find that exciting,
you know what I mean?
To keep pushing myself and
to keep challenging myself
and taking risks, I think it's important
not to get lazy and stay safe.
- This is a really important message,
and one that entrepreneurs
really struggle with,
because when you don't have a boss,
it's really hard to push
yourself to do more.
Entrepreneurs struggle
with pushing themselves
out of their comfort zone because
there's nobody to report to!
And yes, we report to our customers,
if we're under a deadline, or a customer
wants to get this thing
done by a certain time
and you're pushing yourself
hard, you're crushing it
to go out and get that thing done on time,
but if your customer
isn't pushing you hard,
then it's easy to be a little bit lazy!
Not that you're going to sleep in all day,
but you're not pushing yourself
to be the best that you can be.
You maybe taking a little
extra long at lunch,
you may be coming a
little late to the office,
you're going to be spending more time
just browsing around on social media,
or just being a little bit of
a slacker than you should be,
because there's nobody to kick your butt.
There's nobody to say, "Let's do this,"
because when you commit to somebody else,
you're much more likely to follow through.
And when there's nobody
for you to commit to,
as entrepreneurs, we are our own boss,
there's nobody we're committing
to besides ourselves,
we're going to let ourselves down a lot.
And so I think the capacity
and the willingness
to push yourself consistently, hard,
makes the difference
between a really successful
entrepreneur, and just
an average, mediocre one.
And so how do you push yourself harder
when you are an entrepreneur?
A couple ideas, one, have important goals.
Have goals that you look
at consistently, daily,
that are big goals, that are meaningful,
that are important to you, remind yourself
why you're doing this, to
get the energy to get up
and want to push harder every day.
Two, have somebody to kick your butt.
Whether it's a mastermind
group, whether it's an adviser,
whether it's an online group, something,
somebody that you're committing to to say,
I'm going to get this thing done.
I have a mass friend group
that we meet every month,
and in between, you
have a weekly phone call
with somebody in your team,
and you're pushing each other.
Because if you come to that
next meeting the next month
and you didn't do what you
say you were going to do,
the group starts holding a
little bit of flame to your foot,
say like, "What's going on?
"You've been saying that
you're going to do this
"but you haven't, come
on, let's get in shape."
You don't want to come to that meeting
and not have done the things that you said
you were going to do, and
so that accountability
is really important for entrepreneurs.
And then three, we talked
about it a ton on this channel,
the environment and the routine.
It's so easy to get up for one day.
It's hard to get up consistently,
it's hard to keep that energy level high,
and so, build whatever
gets you pumped and excited
into your morning routine consistently.
So whatever you start your day with,
think about what makes you come alive,
again, if it's watching a
video, or reading a book,
or viewing your goals, or
listening to some music,
whatever it is.
For me, it's being around
famous entrepreneurs,
successful people, and
seeing what they're doing.
Yes, their strategies helped
me, that's part of it,
but a big part of it's just
seeing people going off
doing amazing things, makes
me want to push myself harder.
They push me to do more,
because the people around me
aren't really pushing me to do more.
And so whatever gets you excited,
whatever makes you feel
like you want to push
a little bit harder, build
that into your daily routine
as opposed to having it randomly happen
because you turned on
YouTube at four o'clock
in the afternoon.
Build it in, every day, so
you're pushing yourself harder.
So the question of the day today is,
how do you push yourself?
How do you keep yourself accountable
to doing the things that
you say you're going to do,
and reaching your actual potential?
What do you, leave it
in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout-out to Cathy Cashmere
from cccinspire.com,
Cathy, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
it really, really,
really means a lot to me
and I hope you enjoyed it.
Thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you,
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- Hey Believe Nation, for those of you
who want a little more content
on pushing yourself harder,
I think you'll enjoy
these special bonus clips.
- [Interview] And what compels you
to get involved in a project?
I know that's kind of a hard question,
because it's probably so
many different things,
but when you think about projects that you
get involved with, what are
some of the key elements?
- Well, I think, it can be really anything
that gets you interested,
I just want to make sure
I'm going to be challenged the whole time,
because I know if I'm not given obstacles,
I get kind of lazy, I don't really engage
in the way I want to, so, if I know
something's going to constantly
be throwing challenges at me,
not in like, I want to have fun,
I always want to enjoy what I'm doing,
but something that is going to be,
that's part of the fun,
I think, is getting
all of the challenges of it.
- I took this big risk and quit school.
I quit the one thing that was surefire,
and went and became a
model, and got really bored
really fast, and didn't
love being a coat hanger,
and then I became an actor, which was like
a coat hanger that talks, and then,
and then I ultimately just came full loop,
it came back around, and
by the way, when you talk,
you're generally not even
speaking your own words,
you're speaking somebody else's words,
and try to make it sound really real.
And I then did full loop around
and started looking at technology again,
and started getting
interested in technology,
interested in engineering,
and started really getting
interested in solving problems.
Solving my own problems, and then solving
other people's problems and
what the value of that is,
and so whether it's
technology or philanthropy,
or actually even performing,
or being an actor,
I started to make it
about solving problems.
And I think that that's probably
the single biggest thing
that, as an angel investor
I look for in entrepreneurs,
is people who genuinely
want to solve a problem, a real problem,
a problem that exists
not just for themselves,
but sometimes just for themselves
and then it sort of turns
into this wave effect
that solves other people's problems.
And sometimes by trying
to solve your own problem,
you're solving everybody else's problems.
'Cause generally, if you
want to affect the world,
you have to change yourself first.
Everybody tries to go
out and change the world
by changing other people and other things,
but the real way to do it
is by changing yourself,
and sometimes making those
really uncomfortable choices
to go up against everyone in your life
that you look up to, and take
that risk to go be a model,
or go do this thing that
nobody else is doing.
- Basically, what success meant to me
was the opportunity to be useful,
so somebody else might
entertain me as a choice,
but it also meant that
I could use that event
of the success to do something different
than what was expected.
I could go to another genre, I could go
to another kind of role.
I could go from the success of Witness
to the opportunity of Mosquito Coast.
And people say, "Woo, wait a minute.
"Might not be the best career
choice," and I thought,
well, I don't have to make
the best career choice,
I have to make a choice
that will challenge me
and be interesting for me.